Modules are the individual elements that make up an Unreal code base
They're the kind of building blocks that you can stitch everything together from the code side to make an Unreal project
There's a couple of reasons why you might want to introduce a module
One of them is if you have components of code that you only want introduced in particular targets
Such as only in a shipping version of the game, only in the editor, only on a client, only on a server, etc
And that's for whole sections of code
The other reason might be that your project is so large that you start to get really long link times
So modules are a way to break that up to say not all of this code needs to link to all of this other code
You can kind of break it up in that way
And the last point is that modules make your code more reusable
It's a kind of way to chop up a section of functionality that you could then port to another project very easily
Because you know it's relatively self-contained
So what actually is in an Unreal project?
The project at the very least consists of a single module which is known as the primary gameplay module
And is essentially your entry point for your XE
And that primary gameplay module can then link to the other modules it needs depending on what kind of functionality it wants
It's important to highlight as well that when you're building for editor
Each of the modules that your project has are built as individual DLLs
Whereas when you're doing a shipping version of the game
Each of those modules will get combined into one gigantic XE
So if I were to just quickly demonstrate this
We can see here, this is the example project that I've made
And if I went into our binaries, Win64
We can see here we've got an individual DLL for our example 5.5 project
And our example 5.5 project editor
And the reason for that is I've gone ahead and just made an example little secondary module here
For our editor project
I'll go into that in a little bit more detail later
But just to kind of highlight that those things are made as separate DLLs when you're doing an editor build
So if we kind of think about a way of structuring an example here
A slightly contrived example might be that we have an FPS game
And we decide we want to break this up into modules to make it more reusable
So we could have a guns module and then a grenades module
And both of these could then rely on the projectiles module
The advantage of this is it means that we can take guns, we can take grenades
And we can take projectiles all independently of each other and use them in other projects
So our guns would then need to include our projectiles
Because both guns and grenades rely on this projectiles module
So they would both need to rely on it
But it just makes the whole thing more portable
We can take projectiles without the other two
If we wanted to bring guns alone we would need to bring projectiles with it
Because it depends on it
But it just means everything can be kind of chopped and moved around
The one thing to highlight here is if we kind of look at the visual flow
We can see everything is coming out of our primary game module
FPS game being our primary game module
And we need to be a little bit careful about circularity of code here
So we want to avoid circular references here
So we should be very careful about modules linking back up this chain
Guns and grenades shouldn't be linking back to FPS game DLL if they really can't help it
And projectiles shouldn't be linking back to guns
Because it massively increases the chance that you're going to get circular references
Especially as a kind of general working practice
Very few if anything should be linking back to our primary game module
We should really be thinking of our primary game module as the end of chain
An end of that inclusion chain and nothing really should be including that
The one exception I can think of is sometimes when you're using an editor module for your game
That's possibly a case where you might want to include that
But even there if you can avoid it that's a good thing
So when talking about a module the kind of minimum thing that a module needs to be
How it's defined is three things really
We have the working directory
So typically in the engine this would be the most common case for modules that you would already see inside Unreal
Or inside source or runtime
I'll just quickly jump to that example
When you're in an Unreal C++ project you can see we've got it split up between our engine here and our game
And if we go to our source and runtime section
We have a few different sections but the one with the most in it is our runtime
And you can see each of these is a module
So they have their own working directory
If we were just to open up application core
You can see this is clearly a module because it's got its own buildcs file
Which is another component
And then it's got all the source files for that module inside there
So we have the actual working directory so a folder to contain our module
Then we have the buildcs which I just quickly showed before
Which we'll go into a little bit more detail in a second
And then finally we have just a class, a cpp file that actually represents the module itself
Where we can implement that module
So looking a bit more at the buildcs file
This has a couple of different things we can introduce into it
But most importantly is these two arrays of public dependency module names and private dependency module names
We can look at our primary gameplay module here
And if we jump inside here we can see public dependency module names
This is by default whenever you make a new in Unreal Engine project
It will already have a primary gameplay module
It will already have a buildcs and this buildcs will come with these four modules being relied on
It will be very very difficult to create an Unreal Engine game not using these
So they're just in there by default
And so we have the public dependency module names and private dependency module names
The distinction between these two is a little bit important
Essentially it means that a public dependency module name is where anything that your module openly relies on
So when other modules are including this one these are modules that those modules will know you rely on
Private dependency module names are really what we should be trying to use as much as possible
It's not exposing our use of those modules in the same way
It's a little bit more something you'd be needing to rely on when you're doing more engine based modules
You'll see that typically within your gameplay module you don't have a division
Unreal doesn't create an automatic division of public and private here
It treats most of the primary gameplay modules as private by default
But if you look towards any module inside Unreal Engine's code base itself
You'll see you'll get this public and private division here
And that's when your private dependency module names and your public dependency module names become a little bit more important
But just generally I suppose the process should be
Try to use private as much as you can unless something needs to be public
So when it actually comes to creating a module
We can't just put the build CS in, put our module CPP in
And expect the code to get detected and compiled and linked
Otherwise that would be the same as saying we're building and compiling all Unreal Engine's code all the time
Which we obviously don't want to do
So there's a couple of steps beyond just making a module to actually connect it to our game
First and foremost we need to actually link it to our primary gameplay module
This is the most common way of doing it
Or any module that our primary gameplay module is using
So as we can see here again in our primary gameplay module's build CS
We can just add that to a dependent module
So our core, core U object, engine and input core here are going to be getting compiled and then linked
Any modules that aren't included there the compiler isn't even going to think about
Because we're essentially saying I'm not trying to use these for this project
The other thing that we can do is add our modules to a target CS
This is slightly less common but it's really important and powerful and it's an important thing to understand
So whenever you make an Unreal Engine project for the first time
You'll come with your primary gameplay module and you'll come with two of these target CS files
These essentially correlate with the different build targets that we can have
So our example55project.targetcs is used whenever we do debug game, development or shipping
And our 55projecteditor.targetcs is used whenever we're doing an editor target
It covers our editor targets, so debug game editor and development editor
So essentially these target CSs let us highlight modules that we want to use when we're building that particular target
So when we're creating our normal project target we obviously need to include the primary gameplay module
But when we're building for editor we can additionally include editor only targets
So this wouldn't come in by default, this is something I've actually made myself
These two target CSs are in there by default, but I've additionally just to kind of demonstrate this
Added an editor module that would, in a normal gameplay scenario you might add in some developer tools
Some additional editor functionality
So I've added this 55projecteditor, I've included that in our module names
So that when we're building the editor target we want to include this module
And then if we quickly glimpse into this module buildcs we can see I've added my 55project as a public dependency
Again, something we should be trying to avoid when we can
But I'm just imagining that our editor, it's quite likely we would need access to particular actors we've defined inside our gameplay module
Or something like that
But for the most part you should be trying to avoid this so that we don't end up with circular dependencies
But because our primary gameplay module doesn't depend on our editor module
That's not going to be likely
And then we've got our CPP
And this is where we actually implement the module ourselves
Now the other element that gets included and should be borne in mind is the fact that we have
Whenever we're creating an editor module
The way you do that is we have something, we need a class that inherits from a module interface
And that brings with it the functionality to highlight this startup and shutdown module
By default most modules you see in Unreal Engine will have this
They'll have a module header and it inherits from module interface
You don't actually need to do that
If you want a very very minimal implementation of a module
You can actually only have the CPP
And you can use this minimal implementation here where you say implement module
And you just use this F default module implementation
Where if we jump to that you can see that's just an empty class that inherits from iModule interface in the module manager header
So if you really really don't need much control over what happens on startup and shutdown of your module
You can use this
But the vast majority of the time you would have
You would define a module class, inherit from your module interface
And then that gives you access to a startup module and a shutdown module functionality
So once we've actually created the module
The next step that we need to do is talk about how is this module used by our project
When does it get loaded and what type of module is it
The place that you define these is inside your project's UProject file
So I'll just quickly jump to that and show
But we'll come back to this in a second in a bit more detail
But if I just go to our example 5.5 project
You can see I've got my UProject file here
This is actually just a JSON under the hood
So if I open this up with either Notepad++ or any text editing software really
We can see this is what our UProject file looks like
We've got an engine version here, we've got some description and category stuff
But the kind of key thing we're talking about here is this modules array
This is what we really need to worry about here
And you can see we've got our primary gameplay module
The names here are important, they need to match up with the actual name we use for that module
And then we define a type for that module
So this is a runtime one
And we've got our editor module here which is editor and we define a load phase
So a couple of the options we have available to us when we're talking about what type of module it is
And when it loads
The kind of most common ones would be an editor module
Which again is loaded when we're doing an editor target
A runtime module
We also have developer tool which is similar to an editor target
But it's tied particularly to something inside our target cs
Which is this build developer tools bool
When that's set to true that means that this module will get included
That can be useful when you're doing something that you don't want to bring the whole editor with it
But you do need some set of developer tools that you definitely don't want to go into the shipping game
That's a case where it might not be an editor but it might be a developer tool
And then we have server only and client only targets
And that would be pretty self explanatory
It's when you want sets of modules that would only go into the server or only into the client
An example might be you might have all your UI in a module
And then obviously your server doesn't need UI so you don't include any of that code
The second thing is this load phases
Again some typical examples would be just before the loading screen of the game
The default loading phase which is kind of in the middle of the engine booting up
And then post engine in it
Post engine in it is very very common for editor because you want your entire engine to be loaded in
Before you start injecting additional functionality on top
So again coming back to this is just another preview of a U project
We've got the name of the modules we're using
This type is some examples we just ran through
And our loading phase again some examples we just ran through
This isn't a full comprehensive list
If you actually wanted to see all of those you can go to the
If I just quickly jump to the file
It's module descriptor dot h
And in here we have a full list of all the loading phases
And all the host types which is our module types
So if you want to see all the options available to you, you can just jump into the module description header to take a look at those
The other thing to highlight is that modules aren't just to be completely independent of your code base
Sometimes it's not just injecting functionality
But once you've included that module as something that your module depends on
You want actual access to that module
And modules can be accessed relatively easily through this function
The fmodule manager and load module checked
So a typical example and one that I've personally used quite a lot
Is the asset registry module from the engine
So the way you might access that is through this function
fmodule manager load module checked
Then we use the module class type
So in this case fasset registry module
And then we provide this string here
This isn't just an internal name that we give to it
This tallies with what we use in our implement module macro
Which is typically done inside your module cpp
So in the case of our editor, it's this second one here
It's implement module is this important macro to say this module exists
You say which class it's using and here's the name you then refer to this module by
So example 5.5 project editor
In the case of our game, it's the same thing
Our primary gameplay module
If we go to our primary gameplay module cpp
We use this implement primary game module macro
And it's this term here
If we for some reason needed to access our primary gameplay module
It would be using this term here
So that is what you need to provide in this string here
If you want to access that module
What this means is that you can essentially create a module that is just a library of functionality
If you just needed some extra functions to
For example, download some files or provide some http functionality or something like that
Your module doesn't need to bring in a whole lot of different things
A whole load of different classes
It could literally just be a single cpp file with some helper functions in it
And then you could access that through this load module checked
Moving on from modules
But still thinking about that kind of portability that they bring
We can zoom out a little bit and look at plugins
Plugins are similar to modules in that they are separated from our initial project
But they bring a couple of extra features to them
So one of the key things that a plugin has to it
Is it can be made up of multiple modules
If we think about something like
Imagine I've got some advanced 3D pathfinding functionality
So I've got something like a navmesh but it's a 3D navmesh
Then it's clearly going to have a runtime and an editor component
It's going to have the actual runtime navmesh
But when I'm interacting with an editor I want some editor functionality
So that would be a case where that plugin would have two modules
We would have the kind of core module that provides that 3D navmesh
And then we would have an editor module
Because we don't want all of this editor functionality getting exported into the shipping build of our game
So we need multiple modules
If that's the case, a plugin is definitely something that you should be considering
And it brings all that extra capability
The other thing about advantage of plugins
Is that it's got a very nice editor implementation
You can just very easily look up all the plugins available to you
Through your unreal engine
Through the edit plugins tab
I'll just quickly demonstrate that actually
If I jump to our example project
Just hit edit plugins
And you can see all the plugins available to you
And you'll see a bunch of them come in enabled by default
It's actually worth just taking a little look through this in your own time
Because there's whole sets of features here that you might never know existed
Until you start browsing through this
But you can see these are the built-in plugins that come with the engine
Again, not all of these or a lot of these in fact won't be enabled by default
So it's worth looking through them
But you can also install plugins to your engine for additional functionality
So those would be listed here
The last thing about taking this kind of portability idea further
Is that when you make a plugin
It makes it very easy to not just bring it from project to project internally
But it also means you can put it on the marketplace
Either for money or for free
So Fab is the kind of new marketplace for not just unreal stuff
But also I think they have unity and other software on there
And yes, basically turning something into a plugin
Makes it very easy to host up here
And also it's worth bearing in mind that when you're thinking about a new set of features
It's possible that someone already has provided that on Fab
And that might just save you a lot of development time
So just something worth bearing in mind when you're considering plugins
That the Fab marketplace is there
You might be able to put that plugin up there
Or find something and save some time
So when actually talking about creating a plugin
It's very very simple
If you want to make your new one from scratch
The easiest way is just to go to your plugins window
And you can see you've just got this add button in the top left here
If we open that up
We've got a couple of options here for what kind of plugin this is going to be
You can say where you want that to go
And then you can just define some basic information about it
About who's authoring this
What's the description of this plugin
And once you go to create plugin
It will go through a process that will take a couple of minutes
And it will create a new one
But then you'll get something
Your plugin will be created for you
And you'll get something a little bit like this
So your plugins don't go into your source folder
They actually live alongside your project in their own folder
When you create a new Unreal project for the first time
This plugin folder won't exist
Until you try creating a plugin for that project
If you want to pull some plugins in
You can just make this folder yourself
But this will get automatically generated
So this is an example plugin that I made
It has no content really
But it's just to kind of show you the breakdown of it
You'll notice that it looks quite a lot like our actual project
It's got its own source folder
It's got its own content folder
It's got an intermediate folder, a binaries folder
The distinction is you know a plugin when you see it
Because it doesn't have a U project file
It has a U plugin file
The other thing to highlight as well
Is it's got this resources folder
By default this will just have this one thing in it
Which is the icon
And this is essentially what's displayed in engine
So if we actually go and look
You can see my example plugin
This is the icon
If I were to replace this
If I were to replace the icon here
That's what would come up on the editor
So if we just quickly look at the plugin file
We can see very very similar to our U project
Some file versioning
What version this plugin actually is
If this is going to go up in the marketplace
It would have a URL, some support information
And then what modules this plugin uses
So very much like the U project
A plugin can have multiple modules to it
And this works in exactly the same way as the U project
This is where we define the module's name
And then what type of module it is in it's loading phase